(upbeat music)
- Well, it's been a big week for
viral video celeb meltdowns.
First, there was
Chloe Grace Moretz
reaming out newcomer, Brian
Butler, from The Downloader
and then our good
buddy, Kevin Donnelly,
got the business from none
other than Kristen Bell
on the red carpet of The Boss.
Ooh, that was nasty.
A lot of people say
this could be the end
for the legendary correspondent.
We invited Kevin
over this morning
to set the record straight.
Is here here, what's up?
- Yeah.
- Did he show up?
- Seacrest, (claps) Ryan.
Seacrest, do this thing, man.
Come 'ere, give me some love.
We're brothers, we're brothers.
- You and your tighty
whities have a seat.
- This is funny.
I was there and I stood--
- Could you please sit
on the chair though?
- I'm so tired.
- [Mario] Okay, but can you
please sit on the chair?
- I've been up all night.
Your bed is so uncomfortable.
(sobs)
(upbeat music)
- Hey guys, look at me.
- Jesus, Brittney, I've
never seen you run before.
What happened?
- Kevin got fired.
(Man in Suit gasps)
- That is so super sad for him.
- Is he okay?
- I don't think so.
This morning at 6:00
am, he tweeted no.
- We got it, lots of Os.
- This is not good.
- You know what, I'm starting
to feel bad for the guy.
I mean, they're probably
gonna replace him today.
- I've gotta go, like,
right now to a meeting.
- I just started my period,
so I've gotta call my agents.
- You're both the worst humans
ever, you know that, right?
Deca, you too?
- [Deca] I have dreams.
(rock music)
- Things are not fucking good.
I'm the one who's dominated this
whole frickin' town for 28 years
and now I'm in my
car eating Cheetos
'cause I can't fuckin'
get my head straight.
- I'm sorry, I'm being
so rude right now.
- No, it's okay.
- Okay, so, like, was
this movie fun to make?
- Yeah, it was really fun.
- [Brittney] Oh my god.
That's so great.
Oh my god, you're
so interesting.
- That's why I love
this character,
(cell phone vibrates)
you know, George Hotty.
- Oh, wait.
- He's more than just
a judge, you know?
- Yes, yes.
Just, hello?
- Got some good news.
- Yeah, no, no, no, no,
not busy at all, uh-huh?
- Okay, so what are you
wearing under the robe?
I'm asking you a question.
- You should probably
put that down.
- I can't, I wish I
could, I wish I could.
- Oh my gosh, this
is really awkward.
- [Brittney] I'm so sorry.
- Where's my publicist?
- Yeah, I can come in
right now, so sorry.
Yeah, yeah, I'll
be there, uh-huh.
On my way, all
right, just a second.
- Are we under
attack or something?
(rock music)
- I should be in there
talking to Matt Bomer.
Where's the frosting?
Oh yeah, I got some.
(sobs)
- I know what you're
on your phone about.
I figured it out.
It's the Kevin
Donnelly job thing.
- Oh no, I'm just
watching this video.
It's got a panda with a
little paper jet pack on it.
- Let me see.
(both laugh)
- Look at him.
Wait, watch it, watch that.
- [Matt] Oh my god.
(both laugh)
- Oh my god, it's so cute.
- That's good, man.
Do it again.
- Hey, can you keep a secret?
I just got off the
phone with my reps.
Apparently, it's down to me
and one other person for
Kevin's job at The Fix,
so I could get the job and then,
I launch my line of green juices
and then my red juices
and then my beige juices.
- I never had the
chance to tell you,
but I really admire you
and your work ethic.
- Thank you so much.
That is so nice.
You know, I never actually
had an opinion about you,
but after you said that nice
thing about me, I like you.
- Thank you?
- Yeah, I'm not
going back in there.
These people are fuckin' crazy.
Just have the car pick me up
on the side entrance, okay?
Aw, Jesus.
(rock music)
Let me call you back.
Hey there, Kevin.
Hey, wow.
You look like
someone shit in your
cornflakes this
morning, man, you okay?
- Just, just, can you
leave me alone, okay?
- Okay.
Here.
Give me the Cheetos.
- If you're here to give me a
pep talk or try to cheer me up
or anything like that,
it's not gonna work.
- It's not a pep talk.
I just, I wanna
tell you a story.
I was born in Saint
Louis, Missouri
(dramatic music)
and ever since I can remember,
all I wanted to do was be a part
of the storytelling process.
It changed me life and
so I went to New York
and I said, "No, Dad,
these are my dreams."
I had to answer phones
at an advertising agency
called Mesner Vituri
Burger Macknamay Schmeder.
Can you say that?
- I can't say that.
- Neither could I.
I found out that I
had a voice, you know?
♪ Yankee Doodle went to
town riding on a pony
♪ Camptown races sing ♪
Come on.
♪ All the doo dah day
♪ Oh, Danny boy
♪ I love you so ♪
- That's really pretty.
- Yeah, that's when
I realized that
Judge Hotty's perfect
for the whole family.
- I don't know how that's
really relevant to me.
- Oh, it's not.
It's not relevant to you.
I never got a chance to
talk about myself today
with all you
self-involved pricks
and your cell phones
and running out.
- 'Cause I'm the one that's
kind of having the crisis
right here, right now.
- [Matt] Oh my god.
I'm so sorry.
- I'm the one in my
car eating Cheetos.
- [Matt] I'm sorry, man.
- With frosting.
- I'm in junket mode today.
I'm just, oh god, I'm
all about my narrative.
You, this is easy, man.
You need to stop being
a garbage human being.
You have a girl?
You have a guy or?
- I had a girl.
She's in there and she's
trying to leave me.
- So, go get her, tiger.
But you should shower first.
You smell like shit.
- Do I, do I smell bad?
- Literal shit.
(Kevin sniffs)
It's bad.
- I do kind of smell like poop.
- It's permeating the whole car.
I smelled it before
I even got here.
(romantic music)
- Brittney.
- Oh my god, Kevin?
- Listen, Matt Bomer just
told me the meaning of life.
Please take me back, please
forgive me for everything.
I promise I won't
disappoint you.
- Let me think about it.
Fuck no.
(phone rings)
- [Kevin] Is that you?
- Hello, this is Brian.
Yes.
What?
Of course.
Thank you so much.
- [Kevin] Who was
that phone call from?
- I just got the job at The Fix.
- What?
What, that's gotta be
some kind of mistake.
- It is like a mistake, I think.
- The goddamn patriarchy.
- I'm so happy for you.
- Hey, enjoy your eight minutes.
(upbeat music)
- Hey, Kev.
They let you back, oh wow.
Okay, hi.
- Hey, listen.
Guess what didn't
just go very well?
- What, what's that?
- Me, coming back in
here and trying to give,
you know, being the
tiger and everything.
Thanks for the shitty
fucking advice.
- Woah, woah, buddy.
- You know, my career, I
thought it was fucked before.
Now, it's super fucked.
- I was just trying to come
at you from the heart, man.
- [Kevin] I just got super
fucked and you know what?
It was because of your
shitty stupid fucking--
- Take it easy with that finger.
- Stick a fuck up.
Get the fucking
thing away from me.
Stand up.
I'm gonna go outside.
I'm gonna be by my car and
you're gonna come out there
and I'm gonna show you what
it's like to be super fucked.
- Were you rolling?